dans un mois les amoureux de la foire de
tours pourront enfin revivre jauge
limitée exposants moins nombreux les
foires quand même il s'agira d'un
événement pilote en france après une
année blanche pour notamment tester le
fameux pas sanitaires à l'entrée pour la
ville et les organisateurs on reste
néanmoins très optimiste rémy carto un
centenaire ça se fait même entendre qu
vide 300 commerçants seront présents à
la foire de tours 2021 c'est moins
qu'habituellement mais l'événement
restera le plus grand rassemblement
économique de la région
l'entrée sera libre et sans juge mais il
faudra présenter un passeport sanitaire
pourtour événement la foire sera
l'occasion de tester ce dispositif à
très grande échelle
nous ce que l'on va mettre en place ces
des équipes à l'accueil formés pour
contrôler si vous avez été vaccinées si
vous avez un test pcr à nous à nous
montrer si jamais ça va pas vous avez
oublié tout ça on a une petite officine
qui sera là en 30 minutes vous allez
avoir la possibilité de vous vous
détectez pour l'organisation c'est près
de 100000 euros de frais supplémentaires
en 2021 pour un événement qui risque
d'accueillir moins de monde que les 347
me l'entrée de 2019 pas de quoi réduire
l' enthousiasme des organisateurs 6 au
pire des cas on devait avoir même 50 %
de pertes
ça représente encore plus de cent
cinquante mille personnes
quelle manifestation aujourd'hui accueil
sur toi cent cinquante mille personnes à
part la foire de tours y'en a pas un
secteur de la foire est particulièrement
différent cette année le village
gastronomique le point de rendez-vous
incontournable des bons vivants
tourangeau cette année on y trouvera
qu'une trentaine de stands contre une
centaine habituellement parmi eux la
maison ardouin participants historique
de l'événement ça fait plus de soixante
dix ans que nous sommes présents à la
foire de tours on était à l'origine
avant que la foire de tours ne soit à
rochepinard on était sur les boulevards
à tour
et donc on sera encore présent cette
année pour pour effectivement régaler
les tourangeaux qui je l'espère seront
seront au rendez vous parmi les
changements de cette édition 2021
l'absence de stands de dégustation
d'alcool fort pour éviter les
regroupements festif cependant un
liquide coulera à flots à la foire le
gel hydroalcoolique